welcome back to another episode of the
wine down today we will be unpacking
Loki losing it
with the delightful Natasha Rothwell who
plays what if he says BFFs Kelly so we
got a lot of insight into the new
friendship now that Tiffany's child is
born and we talked about in the room how
important it was for us to highlight the
issues of childbirth especially amongst
black women one of the things we talked
about even outside of childbirth as well
as just like women's issues in hospitals
being taken seriously how we have to get
second and third opinions to be taken
seriously okay yeah and so I thought it
was like really cool using Tippie
storyline this episode to sort of speak
to that when Tiffany allows because
she's married because you're the child
now it allows us to talk about issues at
the other three women sure we can't talk
about you know just common issues not
you know think what it happening only to
people that you don't know that seem far
away but it's not these aren't isolated
incidents so it's just important for
awareness so usually our show is pretty
adult but what was it like to work with
an actual baby
in this episode it was wild I wanted to
make sure that baby was okay first cuz
there was a lot happening that day like
this where she shot was very small we
were pressed for time also the mom and
or the parents are right there watching
yes right there and then there's also
like the parents have like baby handlers
so they're like four people looking
after the baby and no we're looking at
[Laughter]
but this was just like it was really
sweet to sort of have that energy and
see how it affected the other cast
members there's something very real that
I think this episode does its we see how
motherhood is affecting Tiffany but also
when your friend has a child
it changes your relationship to that
friend so remember last season obviously
when we've been building up to this
distance between Tiffany and Kelly how
far do you think Kelly and Tiffany have
come since the baby shower
um I think they've reconciled I don't
think there's any animosity but I do
think that Kelly might feel like she has
something to prove as far as you know
like she can be there for Tiffany and so
in a world where Tiffany sort of
preferred her other friends to throw the
baby shower
I feel like Kelly's trying to prove her
worth and doesn't want to lose her
friend to motherhood which means that
they're still in the circle but they
won't be going out late or like you know
we have to have we have to see a matinee
instead of an evening movie that kind of
thing and so I think Kelly doesn't want
that to change
the episode ends on a kind of a big
divide right between ISA asking for a
favor and Molly basically saying like no
just ISA feel betrayed that her you know
quote-unquote best friend doesn't come
through for her in her time of need
of course I think hurt betrayed confused
you know Molly holds her down and I
think to the extent of ISA maybe taking
that for granted you know she she knows
that Molly's busy she knows that Molly
wants this relationship to work but I
think each day just has tunnel vision
specifically when it comes to this block
party it has to succeed and so in Molly
denying her help
it's like she's essentially rooting for
ISA to fail at least in aces mine of
just I'm not going to sacrifice this
relationship that I've been trying to
maintain to help you with this little
thing that might not work in the first
place because you have a history of and
I think that's just free ISA that's a
hard pill to swallow you know given
Molly's choices in this episode what do
you guys do when your best friend
chooses their significant other over
your relationship this is gonna sound
like hyperbole but you do have to grieve
the friendship that you had because if
you kind of hold on to that you're
constantly holding that idea of
friendship as like a ruler to every
interaction you happen they will always
fall short because they have
fundamentally changed and so I'm
consistent like I haven't changed
I still say no thank you for joining us
for another episode of the wide dance
stay tuned for a new episode next week
[Music]
you